et d'ici fin janvier la france où le
couvre-feu sera avancé à 18 heures dès
dimanche dont le bas rhin et
vraisemblablement dans les bouches du
rhône le cher et vaucluse dix nouveaux
départements au total seraient concernés
par la mesure
[Musique]
depuis que le bureau de l' oms en chine
fait état de l'apparition du coronavirus
par décembre 2019 la pandémie a fait au
moins un million huit cent
quatre-vingt-dix mille morts dans le
monde
pays le plus touché en nombre de morts
comme deux cas les états unis avant le
brésil qui a franchi hier le cap
symbolique des 200 milles - orly au
kobus 19 le pays comprennent demi
million de cas confirmés la vaccination
pourrait commencer à la fin du mois
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france même si belgique
réclame donc la destitution de donald
trump lancé une telle procédure ne
ferait que diviser le pays lui répond un
responsable républicain
mais pour la présidente démocrate de la
chambre des représentants si donald
trump ne quitte pas le pouvoir
volontairement le congrès agira ce sont
ses mots
deux jours après les événements du
capitole qui ont fait cinq morts dont un
policier
l'heure est à la colère ce matin j'ai
parlé avec le chef d'état major
américain pour discuter des précautions
disponibles afin d'éviter qu'un
président instable ne lancent des
hostilités militaires ou accède aux
codes de lancement et ordonne une frappe
nucléaire la situation avec ce président
déséquilibré ne pourrait pas être plus
dangereuse un donald trump qui ne sera
pas présente lors de la prestation de
serment de joe biden il a annoncé dans
un tweet laconique à tous ceux qui ont
demandé je n'assisterai pas à la
cérémonie d'investiture le 20 janvier at
il écrit
donald trump deviendra ainsi le premier
président des états unis a refusé
d'assister à la prestation de serment de
son successeur depuis andrew johnson
c'était en 1869 il y à quelques heures
pourtant posture bien différente de quoi
surprendre les commentateurs qui
décelaient un ton très inhabituel chez
lui donald trump rendait publique une
vidéo sur son compte twitter twitter
dont il a retrouvé l'usagé après une
suspension de douze heures il y condamne
alors les violences appel au calme et à
la réconciliation reconnaît en
directement la victoire de joe biden à
la présidentielle et promet un transfert
pacifique du pouvoir
les manifestants qui ont infiltré le
capitole ont souillé le siège de la
démocratie américaine
pour ceux qui se sont livrés à des actes
de violence et de destruction vous ne
représentez pas notre pays et est ce
qu'ils ont enfreint la loi
vous paierez nous venons de vivre une
élection intense et les émotions sont
fortes mais il faut à présent calmer les
esprits et rétablir le calme nous devons
nous occuper de la situation en amérique
avec ma compagne a vigoureusement
poursuivi toutes les démarches légales
pour contester les résultats des
élections
mon seul objectif était de garantir
l'intégrité du vote ce faisant je me
battais pour défendre la démocratie
américaine aux citoyens de notre pays
être votre président a été l'honneur de
ma vie et à tous les merveilleux
partisan je sais que vous êtes déçu mais
je veux aussi que vous sachiez que notre
incroyable périple ne fait que commencer
un donald trump de plus en plus isolé
depuis mercredi gilles et des missions
s'enchaînent dans son entourage ces
dernières 24 heures deux ministres et
plusieurs de ses conseillers ont quitté
leurs fonctions
donald trump également sanctionné même
banni des réseaux sociaux twitter ainsi
suspendu son compte pendant 12 heures
compte facebook vient tout simplement
bloqué l'accès pour une durée
indéterminée une détails avec solène
gaudin c'est le tweet de trop ce
mercredi le réseau social twitter à
retirer une vidéo postée par donald
trump dans cette publication
le président américain s'adressait aux
manifestants qui ont envahi le capitole
leur demandant de rentrer chez eux mais
déclarant sans preuve que l'élection
présidentielle du 3 novembre dernier
lui avait été volé nous avons une
élection qui a été volé c'est une
élection avec une victoire écrasante et
tout le monde le sait surtout nos
adversaires mais vous devez rentrer chez
vous maintenant nous devons retrouver la
paix une vidéo retirée par twitter ainsi
que trois publications sur le même sujet
du jamais vu
malgré l'importance de ce conte aux 88
millions d'abonnés en cause aucune
preuve de cette affirmation
comme l'indiquent le réseau social à
plusieurs reprises sur la page de donald
trump en raison de la situation violente
sans précédent et persistant à
washington
nous avons exigé le retrait de 3 tweet
du compte de donald trump qui ont été
postées plus tôt dans la journée pour
des violations graves et répétées de
notre politique d'intégrité civique
cela signifie que le compte de donald
trump sera verrouillée pendant douze
heures après la suppression de ces
tweets
si les tweets ne sont pas retirés le
comte restera verrouillé et twitter va
plus loin il menace le président sortant
de suspendre définitivement son compte
toute violation futur des règles de
twitter y compris de nos politiques sur
l'intégrité civique ou les menaces
violentes entraînera la suspension
permanente du comte de donald trump dans
la foulée facebook et youtube emboîtent
le pas à twitter le réseau social et la
plateforme ont eux aussi supprimé la
vidéo contestées c'est une situation
d'urgence et nous prenons des mesures
d'urgence appropriées y compris le
retrait de la vidéo du président trump
nous l'avons retirée parce que tout bien
considéré nous pensons qu'elles
contribuent aux risques de violence au
lieu de le diminuer
ce jeudi facebook a sévi mark zuckerberg
son pdg a annoncé qu'il bloquait le
compte de donald trump
les relations entre le locataire de la
maison blanche et les réseaux sociaux
étaient déjà tendues depuis mai 2019
twitter avait alors commencé à épingler
des messages allant à l'encontre de son
code de conduite
trump l'accusant en retour de censure
avec près de 24 mille tweets en quatre
ans pour la première fois
donald trump eux se retrouvent sans voix
sur la toile et john hayden lui prêtera
donc serment dans moins de deux semaines
il a présenté hier son futur ministre de
la justice se sera le juge
merrick garland d' qui dirige la
prestigieuse cour d'appel du district de
columbia où se trouve la capitale
fédérale washington
une revanche pour celui qui avait été
désignée comme candidat à la cour
suprême par barack obama
mais le sénat avait refusé d'examiner
son choix peu avant les élections de
2016 mais un gars landes aura pour
mission de restaurer l'honneur
l'intégrité et l'indépendance de ce
département
fin de citation en france les autorités
sanitaires viennent de donner leur feu
vert à l'utilisation d'un deuxième
vaccin celui développé par modern art ce
qui devrait donc appuyé la volonté du
gouvernement d'accélérer la campagne de
vaccination hier le premier ministre a
annoncé que les plus de 75 ans pourront
se faire vacciner dès le 18 janvier
l'exécutif avait déjà opéré un tournant
en ouvrant la vaccination à tous les
professionnels de santé de plus de 50
ans ou présentant des fragilités
en plus des résidents et personnel à
risque dans les ehpad qui demeure
prioritaire nous nous sommes d'ailleurs
rendu dans l'un de ses établissements
dont le 20e arrondissement de paris où
la vaccination se poursuit support
j'espère que ça va aider les jeunes pour
plus tard ici bien sûr pendant la
première vague quand on a eu des cas
très sévère a eu des décès bien
on était des comme tous les autres ehpad
a été sur le pied de guerre pendant les
deux premiers mois ça a été très
éprouvant c'est pas que j'ai peur mais
enfin sincèrement je prends un peu de
recul pour voir qu'est ce que c'est
qu'est ce que ça donne une fois pas deux
efficacité au niveau de faire des
résultats
effet secondaire tout ça mais s'il
mangeait pas peur parce que c'est une
solution pour arrêter
voilà stopper cette pandémie bah oui
pourquoi pas si c'est une nouvelle taxe
je suis prêt à me faire vacciner
pour ce il faut donner la preuve de
notre bonne volonté en tout cas voilà ma
présence c'est aussi pour dire à quel
point c'est très important
aujourd'hui quand on sait qu'on est à
quasiment 300 morts par jour à quel
point c'est important d'accélérer cette
vaccination est déjà donné tous les
moyens pour pourra pas avancer pour
vaincre cette maladie est l'évolution de
l'épidémie ces deux prochaines semaines
sera déterminante quant à un éventuel
rebond provoqué par les fêtes de fin
d'année depuis trois jours consécutifs
le nombre de cas positifs quotidien
dépasse les 20 mille le premier ministre
l'a indiqué hier la situation sanitaire
est fragile notamment dans l'est de
l'hexagone conséquence de nouveaux
départements vous voir avancer le
couvre-feu à 18 heures dès dimanche 15
préfet applique déjà la mesure depuis
une semaine et elle devrait s'étendre à
dix autres un département dont le bar
ans la préfecture a déjà annoncé le cher
les bouches du rhône les alpes de haute
provence et le vaucluse serait également
a concerné nous sommes en direct par
téléphone avec élire leur baisse conseil
régional du rassemblement national en
région paca
bonsoir merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt français ce que vous nous
confirmer que plusieurs départements de
votre région seront donc
concernés par l'avancement de deux
heures à 18 heures donc ne se couvrent
saut et bien écoutez manifestement vous
le confirmer je ne suis pas dans le
secret des dieux mais comme on nous
l'annoncent depuis depuis quelques
heures manifestement nous allons être
dans les bouches du rhône puisque tu es
le département où j'habite où je vis et
où je suis né lui aussi municipal et
bien nous allons être confiné à partir
de 18h avec un couvre feu donc est ce
que c'est la série sur an est ce que ce
serait la solution si c'était confirmé
ayant pour l'instant ce sont des rumeurs
vous ne savez donc que visiblement pas
plus que nous pour l'instant
est-ce que ce serait la solution pour
contenir la propagation du cosy de 19
écoutez contenir peut-être mais
apparemment au jour d'aujourd'hui est
bien les les cas sont sont toujours sont
toujours assez important et donc ça n'a
pas l'air d'avoir des effets des défis
flagrant puisque de deux coureurs
amateurs en place de cours offerts à 18
m cela fait en fait surtout que ça
lalalalala causé là par là ce que cela
ce que cela démontre surtout et bien
c'est l'incompétence du gouvernement
finalement et l'errance du gouvernement
face à te crées sanitaires une errance
qui se puisse continue qui se perpétue
bien depuis le début de la crise de
lakovic 19 de tous bords les élus font
aujourd'hui seront communs dans votre
région contre cette mesure toute façon
dans tous les cas moi aujourd'hui je
suis dans je suis allé je suis là
exceptionnellement non dans les alpes à
barcelonnette et je suis allez donc voir
un petit peu à la rencontre aussi des
habitants donc c'est dans l'est en
provence alpes côte d'azur je suis allé
à la rencontre des professionnels du
tourisme du ski des remontées mécaniques
ont là aussi on a une fermeture des
remontées mécaniques alors que d'un
autre côté vous avez des des
supermarchés partout dans toute la
france qui sont ouverts il n'y a aucune
distanciation social respecter donc vous
avez une situation qui est complètement
aberrante complètement délirante d'un
côté des stations de sports d'hiver avec
la montagne de l'air pur et cetera où
vous avez donc des gens qui sont obligés
contraint pas d'avoir une saison qui
complètement complètement terminée et
puis
vous avez donc ses hypermarchés où ses
grands magasins qui par exemple à
marseille à marseille quand on peut le
constater on rien aucune règle sanitaire
réel les respecte et donc il ya quand
même un paradoxe il y a une cohérence
absolue des mesures sanitaires et du
gouvernement soit swahili à des mesures
sanitaires réels pour tout le monde
soit et bien on arrête on les
restaurants ou les remontées mécaniques
ont fait vivre l'économie parce que de
toute façon et on voulait il ya quelque
chose qui est à deux vitesses
voilà on a l'impression que d'un côté on
veut favoriser les grands groupes c'est
clair et que les petits commerçants les
restaurateurs et les gens qui se battent
pour le tourisme et pour bella la vie de
tous les jours et bien eux sont punis
réunion de présentation aujourd'hui
entre les élus et l'état
manifestement il n'y en a pas puisque si
l'état l'état redescendu de son olympe
c'est monsieur castex monsieur macron
monsieur vers en redescendre et de leur
olympe qui vraiment très très très
éloignée de la réalité du terrain les
français
et encore une fois je parle de ma région
mais ça se place donc tous les
départements dans beaucoup de
départements en tout cas et dans dans
toute la france et bien je crois qu'il
verrait en valent réellement ce qu'est
la situation économique qui est
dramatique mais alors qu'on balance à
lui parler au jeu et j'ai parlé
aujourd'hui à un responsable de deux
hommes d'une dune de location de skis à
praloup et bien qu'ils me qui me
confiait au fait t'es trop à l'agonie à
la comprenne bien
à quoi est dû ce retard dans l'annoncé
des départements qui seront concernés
par l'avancement du couvre-feu
s'il n'y a pas des changes pourquoi
est-ce que l'annoncent n'at-elle pas été
fait bien plus rapidement par les
préfectures concernées
et peut-être une annonce n'est pas prêt
tout simplement j'imagine jeu j'en suis
convaincu
parce que encore une fois monsieur
vérone monsieur castex ne tape pas où
ils vont ils font des annonces en
fonction de tête
bon alors il fonce comme imaginer qu'il
ya de plus en plus de tests aujourd'hui
qui sont faits sykes on parle de
constater donc évidemment forcément de
plus en plus de cas et puis un
gouvernement qui ne sait pas gérer
depuis le départ donc au finalement
c'est un petit peu au petit bonheur la
chance
alors on prend sur des critères qu'on a
ce sont pas des critères qu'ils ont
roulé à un moment donné il va falloir
qu'elle nous dira clairement quels sont
les critères qui sont pris pour
réellement quels sons qu'il est la balle
de ces critères qu'elle abat
scientifique de ces critères qui sont
pris pour imposé des couvre feux à 20
heures à 18 heures dans les départements
quel est le nombre le stock exact de
vaccins qu'elle est quelqu'un ait été
pleuve le même couple et masque on est
dans l'errance encore une fois on est
dans les rangs sont nés dans 20 ans on a
l'impression que ce gouvernement avance
à l'aveuglette et ça c'est très grave
parce qu'il ne donne aucune perspective
aux français ils ne donnent ils ne
donnent pas l'impression déjà de ne pas
l'impression sérieux et ne donne aucune
perspective aux français alors que
normalement il devrait y avoir il doit
qu'à voir préfére pleinement des
chiffres beaucoup plus clair un tout
dernier mot assez rapidement si vous le
voulez bien un mot sur la situation
épidémique dans votre région il a écouté
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que
dans une situation épidémique dans la
région moi je ne suis pas scientifique
encore une fois je fais de la politique
je ne connais pas quel est l'état de la
situation épidémique
moi ce que je vois dans ma région c'est
qu'il ya des professionnels des
restaurateurs des commerçants des
cafetiers des tas de gens qu envoyer
dans des villages d'aider des cafés des
petites barres des choses fermée et
qu'on dit derrière que des familles
entières qui doit toucher forcément
économiquement et forcément à terme par
le chômage des faillites
et bien moi c'est ça surtout qui le team
qui me qui m'importe
et je me dis qu'elle réponde va donner
le gouvernement à ces gens il va falloir
qui leur donnerait pas qui leur donne
une réponse économique
merci beaucoup d'avoir prétendre agir
sur notre antenne et les hollandaises je
rappelle que vous êtes conseillère
régionale du rassemblement national en
région paca et pour les professionnels
de la restauration encore donc du monde
de la culture c'est donc un nouveau coup
dur les lieux aujourd'hui fermé le
restaurant sans véritable perspective de
réouverture une centaine d'intermittents
se sont réunis à toulouse pour
interpeller l'exécutif
ils demandent des actions et des
décisions claires et concrètes car les
grands champs et grâce d'ailleurs c'est
dans ce lieu de culture et de
militantisme que des intermittents du
spectacle ont décidé de se rassembler
pour échanger autour de la paupérisation
de la profession c'est quand même deux
millions et demi de personnes en france
c'est tous les saisonniers c'est tous
les employés les salariés du secteur
hôtelier du secteur de la restauration
qui eux se retrouvent sans aucune aide
c'est des gens qui rejoignent la
précarité et la pauvreté et mais le
gouvernement ne se soucie pas bhl si les
décisions politiques sont acceptés faute
de pouvoir faire autrement pour la
plupart ils ont bien du mal à les
comprendre et un peu de mal à comprendre
la disparité dans la logique on
entassait des gamins dans des écoles
mais on
les empêcher de danser dans des grandes
salles polyvalentes ou des salles de
sport on va empêcher des gens de se
réunir dans la rue autour d'un spectacle
ou d'une manifestation culturelle et on
va s'agglomérer à 3000 ou 5000 dans un
centre commercial où on va voilà enfin
les exemples on les connaît tous les
transports en commun tout ça il ya un
problème de logique
il ya un problème de logique et de
dignité dans la logique sur sur tout le
territoire et d'un secteur d'activité un
antre pour emmanuel pommard artistes
auteurs si les aides gouvernementales
existent elles ne sont pas du tout
adaptés aux professions du secteur
lorsqu'on m'a pas d'activité si on
n'expose pas si on ne vend pas d'oeuvre
si on ne fait pas de médiation si on ne
fait pas de régie d'exposition on n'a
aucun revenu et aucune assurance pendant
les laps de temps de non activité ce qui
fait que en raison du confinement des
deux confinement toutes les activités de
2020 sont reportés en 2021 et il y à des
aides évidemment mais sur 265 mille
artistes auteurs donc qui rassemble
aussi bien des peintres que des des
scénaristes voilà toutes sortes d'auteur
seulement 2 % ont eu accès à des aides
d'urgence alors que la crise sanitaire
se poursuit sans date de fin certains y
voient même une stratégie
gouvernementale dubé risation du monde
du spectacle vivant avec un accès à la
culture via les vidéos diffusées sur
internet
pièce de théâtre sur une télé c'est une
pièce de théâtre un opéra sur une
tablette c'est plus un opéra et et on ne
peut pas penser que le spectacle vivant
finira sur les réseaux de plateformes de
streaming
c'est impensable et pourtant je pense
qu'ils en rêvent parce que ça
permettrait d'introduire la pub
d'introduire encore du temps des moyens
de faire du fric 1 et du bélize et
encore ce secteur qu'il a qui ne peut
pas l'être pour l'instant mais le
secteur continue à garder espoir et
prévoit d'autres mobilisations avec un
mot d'ordre
fédérer pour cesser de subir
au royaume uni ce pays le plus durement
touché d'europe la situation reste
extrêmement préoccupante ces dernières
24 heures mille trois cent vingt-cinq
personnes sont décédées du courant
navires us un record
le pays est confronté un variant du
cours d'un virus très contagieux
le maire de londres tire la sonnette
d'alarmé évoque la situation dans les
hôpitaux qui risquent de se retrouver
submergé chaud le virus est hors de
contrôle
le système de santé public risquent
d'être submergées ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que nous risquons d'avoir
des hôpitaux à court de lit durant les
deux prochaines semaines si le virus
persiste et si les gens continuent
d'être hospitalisé vous savez en moyenne
dans tout le pays
c'est une personne sur 50 qui est
infecté par ce virus
à londres c'est une personne sur trente
en moyenne dans certaines parties de la
ville
c'est une sur 23 nov
1 3 et la vaccination ce site beaucoup
d'espoir au sein de l'union européenne
qui vient de conclure un accord pour
l'acquisition de 300 millions de doses
supplémentaires du vaccin fighters green
tech doublant ainsi la quantité déjà
commandés de quoi donner un coup
d'accélérateur dans certains pays comme
en espagne on retrouve les screenings là
et oui l'espagne a administré 18% des
doses de vaccins reçus ce soit un peu
plus de sept cent quarante mille doses
qui ont été distribués à travers le pays
et se sont un peu moins de 140 mille
espagnols qui ont été vaccinées alors
plusieurs raisons expliquent ce retard
selon le gouvernement il ya tout d'abord
les avions qui transportait ces doses
qui ont mis plus de temps à arriver que
prévu mais aussi les frigos adéquat pour
conserver ses doses dont certains
venaient du royaume uni alors la période
des fêtes a également été compliqué en
raison des nombreux jours fériés et
niveau organisation pour ne pas manquer
de personnel dans les hôpitaux et les
centres de santé les professionnels
volontaires doivent vacciner sur des
journées complémentaire alors dans son
plan de vaccination l'espagne a établi
une liste des populations prioritaires
ce sont donc les résidents des ehpad et
leur personnel soignant qui se font
vacciner en priorité alors l'espagne
aurait voulu accélérer la cadence en
prenant exemple sur son plan de 20
six nations contre la grippe qui selon
elle fonctionne très bien pour immuniser
à grande échelle alors le gouvernement
se montre quand même très confiant pour
les prochaines semaines il assure que
d'ici les mois de mai et juin
ce sont 20 millions d'espagnols qui
seront vaccinées au portugal la flambée
du nombre de cadres coronavirus inquiète
plus de 10000 contamination par jour et
un record de dix mille 27 cas mercredi
le couvre-feu les restrictions dans
certaines régions seront donc prolongée
et étendue à la quasi totalité du pays
elle déroule durant corp leur esprit
restrictives sont à prévoir pour la
semaine prochaine selon le premier
ministre portugais
je vous propose d'écouter directeur
clinique du centre hospitalier de 10
secondes on est prêt à monter en
puissance en accord avec notre plan de
secours déjà établis afin de donner une
réponse à l'évolution de la pandémie
mais nous sommes préoccupés évidemment
nous sommes préoccupés car nous
assistons depuis l'été à une
augmentation constante de la pression
sur l'hôpital qui se traduit par une
hausse des admissions et le flux aux
urgences les gens doivent prendre
conscience qu'ils ne peuvent pas se
réunir qu'ils ne peuvent pas ne pas se
protéger qui ne peuvent pas être en
dehors de leur noyau familial ni en
dehors du cercle de leurs fréquentations
habituelles
s'ils ne font pas cela la pandémie va
continuer à augmenter et les hôpitaux ne
vont pas pouvoir faire face et donner
une réponse comme ils l'ont fait jusqu'à
présent et plus de 200000 morts liés aux
causes du 19 au brésil deuxième pays le
plus touché au monde par la pandémie
après les etats-unis le brésil qui
compte près de 8 millions de cas
confirmé l'ampleur de la crise sanitaire
est telle dans le pays que dans
certaines grandes villes
les hôpitaux sont au bord de la
saturation françois disque et nietzsche
dans ce cimetière de rio de janeiro
cette scène se répète des dizaines de
fois par jour au cours des dernières 24
heures 1500 24 personnes sont mortes
ducobu 19 dans le pays soit le 2e nombre
le plus élevé depuis le début de la
pandémie
j'étais à l'hôpital et les personnes
présentant des symptômes du coup vite 19
arrivées tout le temps tout le temps
cela ne peut pas être une y est j'ai vu
cela l'hôpital de mes propres yeux
depuis novembre le brésil est touché de
plein fouet par une deuxième vague de
contamination
une seconde vague aggravée par les
rassemblements liés aux fêtes de fin
d'année le seuil des 200 milles morts
vient d'être dépassé pas de quoi
vraiment faire fléchir jaillir ball
sonar haut pour qui l'économie reste
prioritaire
nous sommes en deuil aujourd'hui nous
franchissons le seuil des 200 mille
morts
il ne sert à rien de continuer cette
vieille histoire de rester à la maison
et l'économie on verra plus tard
cela ne fonctionnera pas ça sera le cas
au brésil
et cela peut conduire à des conditions
encore plus dramatique que les
conséquences du virus
nous pouvons pas devenir un pays de
pauvres un pays de chômeurs sans pib et
avec des dettes
nous regrettons les morts mais la vie
continue petite lueur d'espoir pour les
brésiliens
après plusieurs semaines de suspense et
de reports le vaccin corneau vague du
laboratoire sinovac est efficace à au
moins 78 % selon le gouvernement de sao
paulo partenaires de l'entreprise
chinoise
joão doria le gouverneur de l'état
assure d'ailleurs que la vaccination
débutera le 25 janvier prochain après
validation par l' agence de vigilance
sanitaire une crise sanitaire aux
conséquences sociales désastreuses au
début du mois le gouvernement confronté
un déficit public insoutenable a dû
mettre fin aux aides d'urgence versées
aux 68 millions de brésiliens les plus
pauvres soit un tiers de la population
et témoignages à présent de chantal l'un
corcos médecin généraliste à rio
chacun prend l'initiative éventuel
éventuellement de ce s'isoler ou bien de
ne pas sa gle opérer je veux dire les
initiatives sont très sont particulières
et l'imposition du port du masque et il
y a beaucoup de d'entreprise qui
fonctionne seulement on remet en fils
mais les supermarchés les bars sont
ouverts les écoles ont été fermées
pendant très longtemps là maintenant
nous sommes en vacances donc enfin là il
faudra revoir à la rentrée ce qui va
être fait on a comme chez vous les
antilles masquer les antilles vax les
lentilles les anti tau donc à une partie
de la population qui est éclairé ou qui
en fait est consciente de la du danger
est une autre il ne l'est pas et c'est
la fin de cette édition prochain jt dans
une trentaine de minutes à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]